[Musique]
de plus dans nos régions ce qui
m'intéresse le plus qui m'attire dans
vos régions se sait le pays par lui-même
j'entends la topographie du pays
également l'habitat que je trouve très
jolie est ce que vous êtes satisfait des
terrains de camping de notre région
j'en connais deux pour l'instant celui
de wissembourg qui est en cours
d'aménagement
mais très bien situé près d'une rivière
celui de strasbourg mon dieu celui ci où
nous sommes présentement beaucoup moins
et des charente maritime environ de la
rochelle qu'est ce qui vous a incité à
venir en alsace
eh bien je veux retourner dans le pays
où j'étais prisonnier pendant cinq ans
et comment trouvez-vous ce terrain de
camping
le terrain de camping bien eh bien il
est un peu petit mais bien aménagé vous
venez des côtes du nord qu'est ce qui
vous a incité à venir ici en alsace pour
camper c'est à dire qu'on passe
simplement nous d'allemagne c'est la
première fois que la première fois oui
qu'est ce qui vous plaît le plus moi je
veux dire tout ce qu'on a vu qu'on est
le terrain de camping comment le
trouvez-vous
par comparaison à d'autres puisque vous
êtes contrat chez renault je vais vous
dire franchement c'est finalement il n'a
vu des conflits une formidable
vous êtes anglais monsieur je crois oui
madame
comment trouvez vous vous qui avez
l'habitude de camper qui travestit tant
de pays comment trouvez-vous nos
campings alsacien est ce qu'ils sont
bons oprean oui j'aime beaucoup le
camping se trouve cette quinzaine
et c'est très bon
aujourd'hui l'été est fini chacun est
revenu s'asseoir à sa place
pareil et celle du voisin d'une table à
l'autre les mêmes cahiers les mêmes
livres mêmes gestes
oui dans une classe tout le monde se
ressemble
bon mauvais élèves on était là on part
et mener la même vie c'est un peu
anonyme une classe il suffit de poser
une question ou deux alors tout change
qu'est-ce qui est parti en vacances
cette année
vous êtes combien 20 c'est ça hein
merci qu'est-ce qui part de vrai qu'en
vacances de temps en temps une seule
caisse qui n'est jamais parti en
vacances 3 3 6 et 2 8
merci c'est la moyenne un jeune français
sur quatre ne prend pas de vacances au
sens où nous l'entendons aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que c'est les vacances pour
lui et pour les autres d'ailleurs ceux
qui partent les vacances
qu'est ce que c'est
alors voilà pour tous ceux qui ne sont
pas allées cet été en yougoslavie au ban
de l'adriatique a pas que ce style
vas-y bruit alors les infos ici
vous pourrez l'exercent allez vous allez
dire ici ici c'est parti 4
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il semblerait que les fêtes pascales et
donné le coup d'envoi de la saison
touristique en limousin annonciateur de
beaux jours et de vacances ces campeurs
s'arrête sur le terrain de limoges près
des bords de vienne
le camping est un peu un rendez vous
européens anglais allemands belges et
français y plantent leur tente et il
part que leurs caravanes
ce camping de l'image offre aux
touristes des installations sanitaires
modernes est des équipements sportifs
terrain de volley-ball et minigolf le
terrain de camping offre aux touristes
une étape reposante étape que l'on est
souvent à profit pour visiter des
manufactures de porcelaine ou des
ateliers des meilleurs et pour les
limousins qui ne sont pas encore en
congés ces images de détente préfigure
déjà leurs prochaines vacances
à quelques semaines de l'arrivée des
premiers touristes d'été une
constatation s'impose l'île de france ne
dispose pas d'équipements suffisants
dans le domaine du camping et du
caravaning actuellement il n'y a dans
notre région que onze terrains de
camping qui ne dispose au total que de
8000 places frais dryas tout a essayé
d'en savoir un peu plus en consultant le
comité régional du tourisme
et puis on se rendait aussi dans l'un de
ses terrains de camping celui de melun
en seine et marne a 40 km des portes de
paris au bord de la rive gauche de la
seine le terrain de camping de melun la
rochette dispose de près de 200
emplacements destinés à accueillir des
temps de campeurs et des caravanes créé
par le syndicat intercommunal de melun
et de la commune voisine de la rochette
il a ouvert ses portes en juin 1981 en
dehors de la période d'été ce camping
héberge essentiellement quelques
familles de travailleurs caravaniers et
de juin à septembre
il accueille en priorité les touristes
étrangers de passage qui font une halte
de quelques jours près de paris sur la
route de leurs vacances
le passage ce sont des gens du nord
des hollandais des anglais des allemands
qui font une courte étape du jour
deux jours mais nous avons aussi des
gens du midi italiens espagnols suisses
qui viennent passer une semaine pour
visiter paris
c'est d'autant plus facile que nous
sommes à 20 minutes de la gare de lyon
est que nous avons des trains le matin
soit une très bonne idée
c'est très bien organisé pour pour ces
gens là qui rentrent le soir qui
retrouvent leurs caravanes
qui évitait des frais d'hôtel mais le
camping la belle étoile de melun la
rochette n'est pas le seul terrain de ce
type c'est à dire disposant d'au moins
200 emplacements de tentes et de
caravanes de la région parisienne
malheureusement on en compte
actuellement que 11 de cette dimension
sur l'ensemble de l'île de france dont
les plus fréquentées sont celui du bois
de boulogne à paris et celui de
champigny sur marne
de plus la quasi totalité de ses onze
terrains de camping se trouve dans
seulement deux des huit départements de
la région
la seine-et-marne et les yvelines ce qui
ne suffit pas héberger les nombreux
touristes étrangers de passage dans la
région parisienne durant les vacances
d'été estiment les responsables du
comité régional du tourisme et des
loisirs un organisme issu du conseil
régional d'ile-de-france ile de france
souffre d'une grande faiblesse en
hébergement touristes de toute nature
mais particulièrement dans le domaine
des villages de tentes et des
emplacements pour caravanes
nous n'avons même pas en ile de france 2
% de la capacité d'hébergement de toute
la france et c'est pourquoi le comité
régional de tourisme et le conseil
régional ont décidé aussi quelques
années une politique bed d'appui terrain
il faut faire un tel effort parce que la
demande est considérable le comité
régional du tourisme participe chaque
année à cinq ou six salons
manifestations à l'étranger et je peux
vous dire qu'au temps à bruxelles à
utrecht à berlin par exemple nous avons
des demandes très importante de gens
désireux de venir passer huit jours
quinze jours même en région parisienne
avec leurs caravanes et que nous ne
pouvons pas accueillir faute de place
pour développer le caravaning et le
camping en ile de france
les responsables du comité régional du
tourisme ont décidé de participer au
financement du futur terrain de
choisy-le-roi au sud de paris
actuellement en cours d'aménagement sur
plus de 9 hectares à côté de l'auberge
de jeunesse d'un coût évalué à plus de 4
millions de francs il devrait accueillir
les premiers des 500 campeurs attendus à
partir du mois de juin
à plus long terme le comité régional du
tourisme envisage de faire aménager un
terrain de caravaning de plusieurs
hectares près de torcy à proximité de
marne la vallée en base de plein air de
nombreux touristes pourraient ainsi
s'arrêter quelques jours
en ile de france mais les responsables
du comité régional du tourisme ne
veulent pas en rester là
selon eux le développement des terrains
de camping et de caravaning devrait
inciter d'autres touristes à séjourner
plus longtemps dans notre région
celle ci ne serait plus alors une simple
zone de passage sur la route des
vacances d'été
je vous le disais dans les titres tout à
l'heure le littoral du languedoc
roussillon n'a jamais été aussi
fréquenté que durant cette première
quinzaine du mois d'août selon les
estimations qui sont faites le taux
d'occupation est de 100% 100% dans la
totalité des stations
alors on peut imaginer que les
professionnels du tourisme se frottent
les mains
il s'agirait de la meilleure saison de
la décennie il faut dire que beaucoup
d'efforts de promotion ont été faits
pierre bosc la presse la cohue les
embouteillages dès les premières heures
de la matinée c'est la ruée vers les
plages les routes littorales sont prises
d'assaut par des files d'automobiles
pare-chocs contre pare-chocs la baie de
collioure n'est pas seul à connaître ce
grand rush de cerbère au grau du roi
la densité de population a plus que
doublé dans toutes les stations
oui cette année nous avons beaucoup de
monde et les copines son père surtout
sur le littoral 5 complet oui même pas 4
à 100% on trouve encore quelques places
jusqu'au 15 août après le 15 août
l'incertitude plane une forte clientèle
d'étrangers oui notre effort de
clientèle d'étrangers nous avons eu pour
la première fois dans notre département
une grosse clientèle de suédois et
norvégiens qui sont venus en force
l'année dont l'hôtellerie de plein air
camping et caravaning le point de set au
réseau n'est pas loin d'être atteint les
locations d'âge ans enregistre un bond
de près de 10% appartements et
résidences ont été loué en totalité dans
l'hôtellerie traditionnelle on affiche
également complet y compris oui jusqu'à
jusqu'au sage au 17 août 3 et après ça
baissera natale nar vous êtes satisfait
de la saison
comme d'habitude j'ai toujours le même
gars tu auras bien
il n'y a que la restauration pour faire
grise mine à cause des économies sur la
nourriture
une tendance qui se confirme un peu plus
chaque été par rapport à l'année
dernière il ya moins de monde c'est à
dire comment il ya toujours autant de
monde sur les plages nous en restaurant
il ya moins d'argent dans les poches à
les gens consomment moins en
consommation ouais surtout en
restauration bar ont travaillé un petit
peu en restauration dès la semaine
prochaine leurs flux touristiques
devraient s'amorcer en attendant les
records d'affluence seront ils battu en
cette semaine du 15 août
il est encore trop tôt pour l'affirmer
une certitude le languedoc roussillon
tient bien la côte d'amour au lieu de
pratiquer le rafting dans les montagnes
rocheuses passé donc vos vacances en
tipi au coeur de la meuse des tipis
d'indiens aménagé pour assurer quand
même un minimum de confort
deux associations depuis cet été lancer
cette grande première en lorraine
catherine bommel est parti sur le
sentier de la reconnaissance
un petit vent sioux entre les côtes de
meuse plus fort que le gîte rural plus
corsé que le camping à la ferme voici le
tipi l'habitat traditionnel des indiens
d'amérique qu'à trouver au départ j'ai
une double vocation touristique et
culturel parmi les promoteurs du projet
un agriculteur passionné par l'élevage
des chevaux mais qui consacre la moitié
de ses activités aux animations
touristiques par goût mais aussi par
nécessité ou bien trouver des activités
nouvelles
sachant que bon les surfaces agricoles
sont augmentés on a du mal à trouver du
terrain encore pour l'instant ça va
peut-être changer et il faut trouver des
activités qui nécessitent peu de terrain
et qui qui permettent d'utiliser flot
touristique
est-ce que c'est facile d'être un
agriculteur touristique
bref il y a beaucoup de compromis enfin
il faut accepter le chahut le soir il
faut il faut il faut s'ouvrir il faut il
faut bien sûr être l'accueillant il faut
penser un petit peu aux besoins et les
réaliser notamment dans l'ailé les
points d'eau etc
il faut il faut réagir un petit peu en
hôteliers c'est pas toujours facile face
à l'as dit culture touristique un
indianiste convaincu ancien animateur du
zoo de est passionné l'écologie c'est
lui qui dispensent le b à ba de la vie
sous tipi c'est vrai que vivent dans un
tipi traditionnel un type mondialistes
fans ont déjà quelques compétences qu'on
ne peut pas acquérir en cinq minutes et
tout l'objectif du travail que j'ai
réalisé avec mes copains ans rené
philippe et de d'avoir rendu d'essayer
d'avoir dans des tipis accessibles à des
personnes qui n'ont pas forcément les
compétences nécessaires faire du feu
savard vivre occuper l'espace tipi
traditionnelle alors le plancher sur
tous les outils à feu y compris la
grille par étincelles sont destinées à
sécuriser les gens et à leur donner la
possibilité de vivre confortablement
sous tipis quel que soit l'âge même si
on a des enfants et même si on veut
vivre une expérience confortable et
n'ont pas l'expérience de survie ou
propres investis comme ça
et quand la flamme est bien dans le sens
numéro un le feu une étape essentielle
qui fait tout le charme du tipi
puisqu'il est possible et même
recommandé decrease in et/ou de
s'échauffer au feu de bois
je vais montrer en forêt après que les
choses deviennent un peu différent avec
un tipi bateau-feu confort et qui
peuvent être très grands d'un actif et
il faut toujours faire des tifs c'est
mieux pour la sécurité et pour
économiser l'eau le chauffage aussi
doucement vous il n'y a pas besoin et
violent alter sur habiter dans un tipi
permet un rapprochement indéniable avec
dame nature c'est un véritable art de
vivre qui rompt avec le camp fini de
masse l'expérience qui vient d'être
lancée ici correspond à une véritable
étude de marché si le tipi réussi à
convaincre il pourrait devenir un
maillot du dispositif touristique d'un
des départements les plus verts de
lorraine pour nous le tipi c'est un
nouvel habitat des côtes de meuse qui
apparaît aujourd'hui et qui semble bien
là la terre ce qu'on veut lui demander
mais le tipi n'appartient pas l'histoire
locale
non c'est pas lié à l'histoire locale
mais l'histoire elle se fait tous les
jours
alors voilà on va voir les tipis font
partie ni le far west à deux pas de chez
vous qui sait peut-être que les slogans
touristique meusien auront bientôt un
petit quelque chose de sous actualité
fournie souriante avec les vacances qui
tire hélas sur leur faim et déjà déjà
les premiers bilans touristique deux
tendances pour le languedoc-roussillon
une clientèle française en baisse de 8 à
10% par rapport à l'été dernier est en
revanche une hausse de 5 % des touristes
étrangers
inconditionnel de notre région les
belges les hollandais et surtout les
allemands pourquoi
eh bien les professionnels du tourisme
voilà une des retombées de la promotion
engagés par la région en allemagne cet
hiver et c'est beau et si
et la meilleure il a la mer et la plage
il ya aussi les montagnes on veut faire
des courses se promener dans les gorges
et voir les crottes les vacanciers
allemands marque de plus en plus le
paysage estival du languedoc-roussillon
il représente 30% de la clientèle
touristique leur petite famille
s'installe sur le littoral pour un
séjour d'une ou deux semaines très près
des plages lormont est forte les pousse
vers le confort l'hébergement de qualité
camping 4 étoiles l'hôtellerie haut de
gamme économes eu malgré tout il opte
pour un produit fini toute dépense
compris
longtemps fidèle aux plages espagnoles
de l'apostât braves
ils préfèrent aujourd'hui notre littoral
et son arrière pays
je préfère rien c'est la russie de
rossillon parce que je croyais qu'ils
sont pas encore beaucoup le manque mais
j'aime bien de colfer ici la cuisine le
vin
louise le froid c'est ainsi très bien et
allez avec le petit train jaune le
vacancier allemand fui le tourisme de
masse au moins d'affluence il préfère
juin et septembre
la belle allemande nous n'avons pas la
clientèle de masse nous n'avons pas les
charters les autobus qu'on voit passer
sur l'autoroute vers l'espagne mail
interne telles que nous avons c'est une
bonne clientèle une clientèle fidèle
une clientèle qui aime notre la qualité
entre cuisine la qualité de l'accueil de
de l'hôtellerie catalan et je pense que
ça c'est important et c'est ça qui nous
intéresse
après les belges et les hollandais les
allemands découvrent notre produit
touristique pour les professionnels
l'important est de savoir les fidéliser
paris sous la tente comme chaque été le
seul camping de la capitale au bois de
boulogne affiche complet deux mille
touristes venus des quatre coins du
monde car là-bas le campeur français est
une espèce rare
reportage en version originale michel
périer pire brasse caisse visite chez
ceux qui plante la tente au bois de
boulogne
voilà plusieurs fois que antonio manea
revient faire visiter paris à sa famille
alors qu'il ya 50 ans il a travaillé une
année en france j'avais travaillé pied
mais ni les côtés et le bois de boulogne
à ces campeurs ils viennent de slovénie
de pologne de belgique d'espagne
pourtant la réputation du bois c'est
vrai ne tient pas à son camping mais il
est le seul à être situé près du centre
de paris la vie dans les campings est
différente parce qu'il n'y a aucun mur
qui sépare les gens
en fait je peux me promener partout
librement
[Musique]
non
sept hectares cosmopolite propice aux
rencontres si vous vous y allez c'est le
brésil pour voyager avec sa fille non
loin de leur tante de petit matou voyage
amoureusement
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que je fais du
camping et je pense que c'est vraiment
un très agréable
c'est plus sympa de venir ici que
d'aller à l'hôtel
c'est un voyage d'amoureux des français
pour leurs vacances restent souvent de
dépaysement d'îles lointaines laissant
leurs ennuis à des milliers de
kilomètres à calais dans le département
du pas de calais de nombreux habitants
n'ont pas du tout ce même souci pour eux
le dépaysement c'est dans la tête et pas
besoin de faire des heures de voiture ou
d'avion animaux patrick jour ce temps
patrick et marie ont rêvé de ce moment
les valises sont bouclées les enfants au
prix d'un maillot de bain
direction les vacances le stress des
grands départs me semble la plus nerveux
vivement qu'on en arrive là bas parce
que bon ben c'est le grand père on
respire on pense à rien là bas c'est à
deux kilomètres seulement de chez eux
la famille a dit à calais chaque année
elle passe ses vacances au camping de
calais et elle n'est pas la seule
il ya plus agréable à fait on est à peu
près une dizaine dans le coin qu'ils ont
tous de calais l'a hissé derrière pareil
il y en a sur le côté et pour tous et
des vacances parce que bon danseur de la
maison on n'est pas stressés on est en
plein air on est tous réunis bon piont
trade et des attractions contre le chili
tous ensemble pour la paix rend la paix
tentent la belote
même si la vue est limitée d'un côté des
immeubles de l'autre le port c'est leur
petit paradis pour rien au monde une
partir et ailleurs on a les occasions de
rentrer chez nous pour que la femme
puisse laver son linge quoi que ce soit
et en même temps bon bah on n'a pas
toujours le climat mais on est bien
content comme ça a toujours été comme ça
en famille je crois qu'on aurait du mal
à partir
[Musique]
tu n'as pas envie d'être dans un camping
par exemple sur la côte d'azur
oui ça sera voisin de palier collègues
de travail photos de vacances presque
une photo de famille les calaisiens sont
si nombreux qu'ils sont devenus
indispensables à la vie du camping où
est ce que vous pensez à leurs vacances
à des prochaines bon de sûr de revenir
sur calais
la boule excuser parce que c'est l'heure
de la pétanque merci au revoir
ça sent encore les vacances sur l'île
d'oléron
alors que le ciel se voile peu à peu sur
une saison plutôt réussie
huit mille campeurs propriétaires de
leurs terrains doivent tout simplement
décamper avant le 30 septembre
quand on a eu nos actes notariés
d'accord c'était bien indiqué que
c'était non constructible est absolument
pas indiquer qu'on n'avait pas le droit
de dix ans de mettre une caravane valeur
un mobile envoi sur le mien c'est pas
notifié c'est normal c'est une chose
normale
le propriétaire d'un terrain il fallait
pas nous laisser et à 17 ans la
préfecture de charente-maritime relayée
par les huit maires de la communauté de
communes de l'île d'oléron veux tout
simplement faire appliquer la loi
littoral et préserver l'environnement en
mettant fin à certains abus installé
depuis plus de 20 ans certains campeurs
bénéficier de tolérance mais pas
d'autorisation officielle
il faut que ces espaces qui sont malgré
tout occupé par des conteurs isolé
retrouvent leur vocation d'origine sans
que que cette légitime de la part des
élus et non seulement oléronnais
d'ailleurs tous cas à ma connaissance
sur tout le littoral atlantique
cela suppose ce problème là actuellement
à la pointe du combat mourice grisons ce
retraité ancien agent d'assurances
propriétaire d'un terrain et d'un
mobil-home veut négocier avec les maires
au cas par cas
juridiquement parlant nous ne sommes pas
défendable puisque nous sommes derrière
il faut donc essayer de penser autres
trouver une jolie girons a merdé avec
mais chez les verts et le croyait dans
des coloris td qu elle est si le
dialogue s'avère impossible
les campeurs expulsables envisage
d'organiser une grande manifestation sur
l'île d'oléron
20 heures de bus à 80 km/heure ce groupe
de slovaques arrive de bratislava pour
la première fois un tour operator de
slovaquie a réservé une vingtaine
d'emplacements au camping rigueur de
l'est il écoute discipliner les
instructions de michel le représentant
de la gent slovaques passent on était
ici les familles dépensent mille francs
pour huit jours tout compris
repas et excursions une somme malgré
tout conséquente pour la classe moyenne
s'il y a une famille à 4 manquera il
doit faire l'économie totale pendant
quatre mois quatre mois ils doivent
mettre leurs salaires à part alors c'est
cet hymne grands sacrifices pour les
repas la moitié des denrées alimentaires
a voyagé avec les touristes
l'argent de poche est quasiment
inexistant mais l'important n'est pas de
dépenser c'est de découvrir
on est parti à mon accord à 15,10
dollars venant bien profiter aussi on
était fatigué mais c'était très très
joli changement de décor promenade des
anglais
une promenade russe où les prix des
matelas et des parasols sont traduits
après paris yuri un homme d'affaires
d'ukraine pas sa deuxième semaine de
vacances sur la côte d'azur prix du
séjour
vingt-six mille francs pour sa famille
c'est sûr c'est un gros budget pour un
niveau de vie moyen mais nous on peut se
le permettre
les russes font escale dans les hôtels 3
ou 4 étoiles leur séjour est réglée aux
agences avant leur départ pour les
suppléments c'est différent au niveau
des dépenses entente extra minibar
téléphone restauration tout ça s'est
fait de manière en espèces en dollars en
dollars et en régional andorre une
publicité pour un casino dans un
magazine en russe le signe que les
valises de dollars ont trouvé leurs
marques sur la côte d'azur de l'argent
frais pour le commerce
parfois de l'argent sale selon un récent
rapport des renseignements généraux
certains touristes russes ont déjà
investi dans l'immobilier pour les
vacances bien sûr mais aussi pour
d'autres affaires plus discrète
apparemment c'est un camping en fait
c'est tenter ces caravanes sont
implantés sur des propriétés privées et
sur l'île de ré c'est totalement
interdit puisque depuis 1979
neil est un site classé de mille
campeurs qui possèdent leur terrain
depuis parfois plus de 30 ans ont peur
de perdre leur coin de paradis
vous savez nous on habite un appartement
à côté d'eux les l'anniversaire et il ya
pas mal de monde alors ici on vit ici 1
paul neveur et maire du village de la
couarde il a décidé avec les autres élus
de l'île de faire appliquer la loi
nous appliquons la loi nous dresse un
procès-verbal ça ira chez le procureur
et le tribunal jugera et puis il y aura
une astreinte financière qui l'a sera
lourde
donc les gens sont bien obligés
d'évacuer sinon ils seront obligés de
payer et c'est comme ça quand ils
tiendront il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas
de police
régulièrement les campeurs sur
propriétés privées manifeste c'est clair
ils ne veulent pas quitter un terrain où
souvent ils ont procédé à de nombreux
aménagements envoyer au moins de crs
envoyez-moi les gardes mobiles chez toi
tu maintenant une bombe mais pour
l'instant je suis là je voudrais pas
selon la loi
seul le ministre de l'environnement
dominique voynet peut accorder des
dérogations vous ayez un envoi n'est que
en fait la protection du site de l'île
de ré ne passe pas systématiquement par
l'élimination des campeurs et
caravaniers sur parcelles privées que
même avec des compos caravaniers sur
parcelles privées dans l'île de ré le
site peut être protégée et
l'environnement si l'association de
défense des campeurs privé demandent des
regroupements de terrain comme ici
impossible répondent les élus
c'est désormais illégal affaire
compliquée le vent n'a pas fini de
souffler sur l'île de ré depuis des mois
ils rêvaient de leurs vacances d'exhiber
fièrement leur petit maillot de bain sur
la plage se tartiner de crème solaire
pour le moment le maillot est toujours
au fond de la valise et c'est un autre
équipement qui semble plus approprié
toujours l'imperméable et les bottes
quand même au cas où la pluie qui sapent
le moral au camping municipal les
nouveaux arrivants font grise mine
leurs vacances serait-elle déjà gâché un
peu aussi quand même parce que la plage
c'est pas évident en plus ces 4 juillet
aujourd'hui où le feu d'artifice ça va
peut-être pas être la grande joie pour
tout le camping ou presque
l'activité du jour s'est défilé du 14
juillet à la télé on viens de regarder
le défilé mais il pleut à paris encore
plus qu'ici je crois ça me console bon
non un malheur de l'un fait pas l'autre
malheureux aussi ce restaurateur au bord
de la plage 15 serveurs des zéro client
profite ce trafic par rapport à l'année
dernière c'est encore pire
2 entretenir des personnes pas de
clients personnes tous la plage se
promènent à rien mais ils le savent ici
en quelques heures le temps peut changer
demain c'est promis c'est pour le soleil
qui sortiront
[Musique]
avec les vacances la grande ascension a
commencé sur la dune du pilat chaque
année on compte plus d'un million et
demi de visiteurs le site donc le plus
visité d'aquitaine mais aussi une énorme
masse de sable qui n'arrête pas de se
déplacer reportage david bazié bernard
bonne arme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la dune du pilat c'est tous les jours
l'étape de montagne il y a les grimpeurs
les grands baroudeurs et ceux qui sont
avoir fait la dune c'est ça qui est beau
même si essoufflé c'est très dur à
l'arrivée de faire des commentaires sur
la télé je mente
c'est le défi de faire et puis est en
contact direct avec la nature une fois
grimpé sur le ventre du monstre de sable
100 mètres au dessus du bassin
d'arcachon la plus belle vue de la
région et du sable du sable du sable ça
évoque ce que ça y est j'ai fait mon
service militaire au sol c'est pareil
soit rien fait dans les îles pacifique
magnifique ça plaît tellement que le
site reçoit un million cinq cent mille
visiteurs par une foule de plus en plus
nombreuses qu'il faut accompagner chaque
saison la commune de la teste installe
son gigantesque et sky
il ya d'autres excès à la lune mais on a
souhaité pouvoir canaliser les visiteurs
de manière à ce que cette ce flux
importants passe par un endroit que l'on
peut organiser entretenir régulièrement
car la dune et surveiller étroitement l
avance de 4 à 5 mètres par au camping de
la dune le directeur christian bidon a
vu sa piscine disparaître ensevelies par
le sable
voilà nous sommes sur la dune est ici à
la verticale se trouvait la piscine
jusqu'en 1985
on a donc reconstruit la piscine le plus
loin possible de la dune elle nourrit
mais elle nous mangent donc comme elle
nous nourrit il faut l'entretenir il
faut la soigner il faut veiller à son
évolution
et puis elle nous mange c'est celle
irréversible c'est l'irrémédiable
irrémédiable mais les études le montrent
ce n'est pas le tourisme qui fait
s'affaisser la dune c'est la nature
impossible de les rater
tous les jours sur le bord du parcours
ses trois campings cars attendent lilian
jégou le coureur préféré de jean yves
chantal et brigitte des heures de
patience pour quelques secondes
d'encouragement
sauf que hier lille angers vous s'est
fait désirer
[Applaudissements]
l'étape de montagne lui a été fatal et
c'est dans la voiture de son équipe que
ses supporters le voient passer
[Musique]
déçu mais pas résigné à l'est les trois
couples repartent aussi sec arrêt prévu
quelque part entre cap les marseillais
au delà pour pouvoir redescendre sur les
942 ont étudié parcours avant de façon à
ne pas perdre de temps pour rattraper
après la prochaine étape
pourquoi c'est important ça ne veut pas
perdre de temps et vient pourrait avoir
des meilleures valeurs et c'est parti
pour deux cents kilomètres ça coûte cher
toujours qu'il va donner raison
[Musique]
le tour de france version quand il car
ces 5000 kilomètres des paysages sans
cesse renouvelé c'est la deuxième fois
que jean yves le fait ces masses on a
pris trois semaines de vacances mais
bien de vélo et puis bon bah on voyage
en même temps on voit du pays on
rencontre des gens là on a rencontré des
amis ça fait quatre jours on va
sympathiser les gens contre comme on ne
connaissait pas qu'on n'avait jamais vu
on a sympathisé et puis ça y est on va
faire le tour ensemble
comme chaque soir ils rejoignent le
parcours de l'étape suivante
le plus dur reste à faire trouver un bon
emplacement
[Musique]
cette figure de la place pour trois
j'ai commencé la course
[Musique]
hu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
drapeaux en place le campement est
maintenant prêt malheureusement
abandonner une pensée pour lilian jégou
même si tous ont décidé de suivre
christophe moreau toujours en course la
question qu est ce qu une yourte peut
bien fabriqué au coeur de l'ariège
c'est simple c'est la nouvelle résidence
secondaire de marie pour sa retraite
cette soixante huitarde a décidé de
quitter le plus souvent possible et sa
cuisine équipée parisienne pour cette
source de 20 m² beaucoup de nature un
petit air de mongolie et un intérieur au
final plutôt cossu mari vient ici
quelques semaines de temps à autre mais
elle ne s'est pas transformé pour autant
en apôtre d'une vie 100% rustique il ya
une certaine satisfaction à réinventer
le chauffage bricoler bon tout ça c'est
très hypocrite parce qu'en fait on se
passerait absolument pas de ça mais se
donner ce sentiment de temps en temps
qu'on peut on peut on peut vivre sans
qu'on n'ait pas aliéné à prompt à le
ciapa le 73 capes à la télé hier par
téléphone
marie n'est pas la seule à avoir
succombé aux charmes de cette drôle de
tentes dans laquelle les mongols le vif
pour de bon 148 se sont vendus cette
année pour 4000 euros on vous la livre
en kit
après il n'ya plus qu'à la montée tout
simplement
[Musique]
dans un autre style plus chic plus fous
et plus glamour plus haut à 15 mètres du
sol la cabane nicolas roger irène
peuvent admirer leur somptueuse
propriété normande
il adore jusqu'à dix ans vous sentez un
oiseau est presque parce que c'est
tellement fou c'est vous m écoutez on
sent le vent on a vraiment l'impression
de mourir
et oui c'est la cabane de nos rêves
d'enfant mais en beaucoup plus solide
donc en beaucoup plus cher une cabane à
70000 euros
qui l'aurait cru
[Musique]
elle se prépare depuis deux bonnes
heures dans la jungle car dans le
camping les soirées du lundi son digne
de celle d'un samedi soir
moi je préfère coiffer fc le maquillage
auprès de maquillage parce que shebab a
fait les ce qu'elles ne disent pas c'est
que sur la scène du camping elle les
centres quand peu sont les stars de la
nuit au camping des vagues
ils sont un bon millier bien décidé à en
faire des vagues
[Musique]
franchement fabi cirelli a rien de mieux
c'est pour que pour les jeunes
franchement elle a rien à dire je vous
conseille à tous de venir les vagues ça
cloche pour mener les coulisses campeurs
et animateurs se croisent pour trouver
plus vite que tu m'avais fait paniquer
la plus relax maintenant nos stars d'un
soir ont flashé sur les nuits du camping
non bien vraiment pour l'animation à ce
qui est bien c'est que pour les jeunes
c'est bien parce qu'on peut s'amuser en
journée et en soirée on pouvait les
spectacles situe à la discothèque
guerrière donc pour les jeunes bleus
quand même bouger sans forcément sortir
ce n'est pas la voiture
ils connaissent la chanson
hélas le sombre tous les matins ils
révisent leur part toujours en famille
et bien sûr avec les animateurs
[Applaudissements]
et pour ceux qui ont encore un peu de
force
la nuit n'est pas terminée la puce il
sort en boîte un même avec des bébés
clubbers et leurs parents l'ambiance est
digne des meilleures boîtes parisiennes
grâce aux danses du camping les fameux
crédits sign jacques gros clubs à ta
propre musique
en commençant ce qu'on appelle et klein
et après on a nos musiques à nous et à
prendre en inventions du doubs flammes
il dit que du soleil et sous le soleil
de valras justement à l'heure qu'il est
nos campeurs sont déjà en train
d'apprendre de nouveaux pas pour le show
de ce soir
[Musique]